so uh every time i talk to like a i'm
going to call you guys a young cast i'm
i'm which you are
actual or young
yeah
a young cast that uh that you know when
there's a few of them on set they
usually start a group chat so i'm just
curious if you guys started a group chat
and who is the one who texts too much
no group chat for us but we did hang out
a lot i swear we probably had one
because we had that whole step brothers
oh we did no we did it we did one i feel
like it's so weird because logan has and
andrew who is this guy the green texture
yeah yeah so like his green messages
no yeah i i feel like
who texted the most probably is it's
okay you can say it you yeah yeah you
can call me it was probably that's fine
that's not a bad thing i get so scared
because i want to text you all but then
i get scared that you're like oh my god
no touch them too much so
but yeah mckenna probably yeah
i was the one who made it i think yeah
i like the honesty um i love learning
about the behind the scenes of the
making of films and tv shows what do you
guys think would surprise people to
learn about the making of this movie
um
yeah i don't know i mean um a lot of
it's practical a lot of the effects are
practical um the creatures mostly except
for like you know the flying ghosts that
uh are like puppets stuff like that
um behind the scenes i don't know i mean
jason um you know
allowed crazy
leniency when it came to performances he
allowed me to improvise a lot which is
awesome um
his script with gill gil keenan that he
wrote is so good that like i almost
never did but when i had an idea i could
go up to jason and talk to him about it
and that was pretty amazing oh well
that's something that i did um
with jason for me it was like really
specific like less on the lines but for
the performance it was super specific um
but one of my favorite things is that i
tell a lot of jokes in the movie and
every single take i told like a
different joke like those were my jokes
that i came to set with so
uh they're just jason's jason's picks
jason's favorites are in the movie so
but and there's so much um
there's a lot of scenes that were uh cut
out and yeah in the film yeah there was
a whole like plot point that was like
room yeah stuff and it's really cool but
it ended up working out so well yeah i
the the cut is so like incredible i
literally was like oh we shot other
stuff i don't even remember so there's
like i'm excited for people like maybe
they'll be on the blu-ray or whatever
like the deleted scenes those are pretty
fun and cool
it's funny you bring that up because
that's literally my next question i
rewatched some of the trailers last
night and in the new trailer there's
stuff that's deleted from the movie um
yeah that's
you know i don't know why i think
studios do that to like really make
people the trailer scenes yeah because
actually that's why they put them in the
trailer because like i don't think they
work as full scenes like you could use a
clip and it would be great but like
maybe it doesn't work as an entire thing
in when you watch it as a full movie
yeah there was like a whole plot point
that that's different
yeah totally yeah no i'm excited for
people to see that too that's like a
really fun that's my favorite part as
like a fan of
you know
movies in general um watching the
justice league we'll release another one
and it'll be the right man cut the
rightman cut no this is what's awesome
that's also what's amazing this is the
raymond yeah it's so cool um
you know it was jason's idea to you know
trim the fat as they say so yeah so
completely what what ended up being like
really the toughest shot for each of you
to pull off like the one that really was
a pain in the ass
oh that's a great question
all this the final act uh was really
hard yeah but like so amazing like and i
can't really spoil it i'm trying to
think there's a scene where i'm on the
gunner's seat and there's like wind
blowing dirt into my face and that was
like three days straight and you'd go
outside and you'd blow your nose and it
would just be like dirt out yeah i have
a picture of a q-tip that i use it was
just covered in dirt uh i'd say the most
complicated is actually a shot that
wasn't in the movie it's like this
boogie nights one take shot that
actually makes the movie like longer
it's a really cool shot but it's like it
doesn't there's a scene where like
celeste o'connor's character lucky asked
me to go hang out with her friends and
i'm cleaning and then i take off my
apron and i go and i get in the car with
them that was like a way longer scene it
was like she's like you coming with i'm
like yeah and i see her walk out of the
door
and then i follow her to the window and
i see her and i follow her and uh it's
like a one dick and i take off all my
stuff and i run
out the door then i jump into the cars
the car is moving as the car is moving
oh um
and
what's called that was a really cool
shot again
because i think jason like jason
actually had a lot of one takes in the
movie which is so funny he had like two
or three
but they're so long that like it kind of
takes the momentum out yeah so they cut
it really nicely yeah
i mean
i mean it
rarely you know i'm really proud of a
lot of things that i do um which is nice
a lot of projects but like this one
truly is like amazing i'm really proud
of it my hardest scene was one that got
cut out as well really yeah there was a
whole bit where i i took the proton pack
out into a field and that's right so
that was like an entire day of just
lugging this huge thing i had like red
marks all up and down my shoulders
afterwards like my shoulders were raw
from it rubbing because because they
were like doing his light pack and i was
like no it looks better with the heavy
pack um
and it was just me like running through
this field with this thing on for and
the acting like doing that is so hard
it's just yeah
ah and he's like be louder oh yeah yeah
it was really difficult there was like
bugs all over my legs but it was still
like the coolest no i just done but i
love that part about like the mystique
around you know
deleted footage i think as well yeah
excited but yeah the movie is amazing
i'm really excited about it on that note
i got to stop congratulations for
reading so much hope it's a huge hit
thank you so much
you